こんにちははじめ社長ですはいというわけ
で今日はですね2014年はじめ社長反省
会ということでございますはい昔から見て
くださってる方そして今年から見て
くださった方もう皆さん本当に今年は
ありがとうございました是非来年も
よろしくお願いしますと言いたいところな
んですけど
もまその前に反省会だわな反省会だわ今日
はねその2014年に俺がまどうだった
かっていうのちょっと自分なりにこう反省
していきたいと思いますはい僕はね
2013年のなんか年末タグみたいな動画
を出したんですけどその動画の最後に
2014年は俺の年にしてやるって言った
んです
よま俺の年までは行かなかったんですけど
もますごい飛躍の年になったかなと思い
ました今年の最初は登録者た20万人行か
なかったぐらいかなそれぐらいから始まっ
てま今じゃ90万人超えてるぐらいで本当
にいろんな人に見てもらえるようになって
いろんな方から評価をいただけるような
感じになってなってきたなと思っており
ます本当にいつも見てくださって応援して
くださる方本当にありがとうございます
まあ2014年はあれだなま伸びた分
やっぱこう一目につく動画もあったし
やっぱね中にはねこう過激な動画とかこれ
はどうなのとかそれ危ないんじゃない
おかしいんじゃないもったいないんじゃ
ないのっていう攻め攻めの動画もあったと
思うんですけど
もままあまあまあまあまあやっぱいろんな
人が見てるんでねこういろんな考え方
いろんな思いがあると思うんで全員が俺の
動画を見ていい気持ちになるとは限らない
ていうことはも分かってるんで来年もねま
相変わらず自分のしたいことを好きなよう
にやっていきたいと思いますうんま周りを
気にしてちゃあねま自分の好きなこともし
たいこととかも本当にしたいこととかも
できなくなっちゃって常識に囚われちゃう
と思ってるんでま最低限本人はくれない
程度にねま好きなことやっていこうと思っ
てますいやちょっと過激なのは多かったで
もアパートの4回からプリンを落とすやつ
とかもめちゃくちゃ叩かれたからねま色々
あった2014年でしたはいというわけで
今日はですね2014年に出した動画の中
のベスト5を見ていこうと思っています
よかったら是非お付き合いくださいませ
じゃあ見ていきましょう第5位ですこちら
です巨大な水風船にジャンプでブレーブ
バスト前回ちょっと前にですねあの巨大
風船若バカでしょ入れろとかりのうんこれ
はねえっと超巨大な風船に水を入れて
ジャンプでシャってなる動画ですいやよく
やったよマジで
これはねもう本に純粋に僕がやってみ
たかっただけなんですようんすごい
楽しかったですありがとうございます第4
位はい第4位はこちらですねえっと今年
からちょっとこう見てくださる方を交えた
動画っていうものをねちょっと作って
いこうと思っててまそれの第1弾でま30
人同時PKってこと
です本当にこの時手伝ってくださった皆
さんありがとうございました
[音楽]
いや
正直止めれると思ったんすよ止めれると
思ったけどちょっと無理でしたね第3
位3位もね引き続き視聴者さん参加型の
動画でございますえっと水学部の人をこう
募って何人かな80人ぐらいかな結構
集まってくれてで器は何か教えてなかった
んですより集まってもらて
でオーケストラをしますってもうその日に
言ってみんななんかふみたいなふみたいな
感じでまみんなでやった感じでございます
俺もねオーケストラ詳しくないんすよまで
もなんか見よ見真似でこうやっちゃった
感じがあったんですけどままあまあまあま
ぽくなったんでまあ良かったと思います
本当にこれもね撮影がとても楽しかったん
でまランクインということになっており
ますありがとうございます第2位選択のり
4本ですよ前回3てさてたん今年はね今年
はねもう俺これのイメージなんですよは
なかスライムてイメジ
です1回スライム作ったんですけど失敗し
ちゃっ
てからるでもう1回リベンジするいう動画
もう個人的には今年の俺の顔みたいな感じ
だと思っておりますこれが第2位でござい
ますぜひねぜひ見てみてください第1位第
1位はねもうこれ
ですね再生回的に第1位ですコーラブロに
体中メント入っ
てやった本人が言うのもんんだ
けどですね本当にこの時はねちょっとね今
もってるけどちょっと申し訳ないちょっと
もうやりたすぎて仕方なかったんですよ分
これが第1位でございますぜひ見てみて
くださいねはいというわけで以上がトップ
5でしたま他にも結構あると思うんすよ
モンスターシリーズとかモンスター
シリーズとかつっぱり棒シリーズとかこう
色々あったと思うんですけどもまここま
ここら辺がね今年僕がやってて面白かった
です個人的にはいという感じの反省解で
ございましたまあな見る人も増えるから
いろんな意見があると思うんですけどもま
基本的に何も気にせずね本当にダメなこと
はちゃんと僕の身近な人が注意してくれる
んでね自分のしたいことをただ楽しんで
やれればなと思っております今年は本当に
いい年になりました皆さんのおかげで
ありがとうございます来年
は取りに行くからなじゃあ
[音楽]
な